los medios locales británicos citan
asegurando que el Primer Ministro Richie
sunak ya le pidió al ministro de defensa
que investigue Qué tipo de aviones de
combate podría eventualmente el Reino
Unido entregar y a largo plazo si esta
posibilidad se concreta seguramente
habrá un gran debate nacional político
sobre la conveniencia o no de entregar
esos tanques pero ya las opiniones están
divididas por un lado el ex Primer
Ministro Boris Johnson dice que sí que
deben darse rápidamente sus aviones de
combate para la victoria ucraniana que
además debe acompañarse con más tanques
Pero por otro lado sectores de partidos
de oposición aseguran que cualquier tipo
de respuesta o entrega de aviones debe
ser coordinada con la otan entre tanto
les cuento Que hoy el Reino Unido ha
endurecido las sanciones contra Rusia ha
sancionado a ocho individuos que apoyan
financieramente al kremlin seis
entidades proveedoras de material
militar que han entregado como drones y
a una entidad financiera relacionada
también con el kremlin